Hey, hello, hello everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Okay, guys, you see all there's some new stuff on the screen
and I hear myself.
Oh, no, okay, I fixed it.
Okay, I don't hear myself anymore.
Okay, hello, everybody.
I'm so excited to show you guys all these things on my
screen.
You're like, oh my god, it looks so fancy.
So I'm going to post this right now.
out so what is this fancy thing that's going on on the
screen at the moment so here i post this uh let me pin this
real quick so basically i downloaded this from i was like
following this this uh creator that does like widgets uh for
stream stuff i've always wanted to use it it's like a
streamer task list widget and then all you have to do i
don't know if it if it doesn't pop I'm sorry.
I saw someone already tried it and nothing popped up.
Okay, I didn't know.
Guys, give me a sec.
Let me figure this out.
I thought that was how you do it.
Okay, task command, permission.
It says viewers.
Why is it not viewing?
I was able to put stuff on.
I don't know about you guys.
Okay, did I like mess it up?
up okay uh give me a sec i didn't like actually yeah it says
add adds news task to the list yeah exclamation point add
what the fuck why is it not working i was able to okay watch
this add uh um add uh fix the to do list fix the to do list
Am I?
Am I even, am I not on anonymous mode?
Am I on anonymous mode right now?
Give me a sec, guys.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I forgot I'm on anonymous mode on Twitch, so when I'm on
anonymous mode on Twitch, I can't do anything.
Okay.
Oh no, give me a sec.
I can't even load Twitch at the moment.
Oh, It's all over.
It's over already.
I was, it was so cool, too.
I was like, oh my God, this is so cool.
I can, like, add stuff.
Oh, wait, is this why?
Wait, I think I know why it doesn't work.
Give me a sec.
Oh!
It was the wrong command.
Okay, I fixed it.
All right, now it should work.
I figured it out.
I gave you guys the wrong command.
There we go.
What do you mean?
It's Jovert.
Set up new.
I can delete I can literally delete commands
Guys, please this is supposed we're supposed to be working
together Chat we are supposed to be working together chat.
Stop I will delete your commands.
Wait, no mods can delete commands.
I'm so sorry.
I know like, okay, I've started paying the mods though you
can't be like they're doing it for free because i can
finally afford to pay the mods so like boss why okay all
right all right mod you're getting paid now
so my all you have to do is it's the command to delete other
people's uh the command to delete
that are not relevant is delete so it's exclamation point
wait let me read the i'll let me read the guidelines okay
it's exclamation point delete and then you i swear to god
and then like delete the username all you have to do is just
like exclamation point delete and then you delete whoever's
username has like the shitty task that is not relevant you
just do delete the username's
So, not enough for, what do you mean?
Look at all my tasks.
Look at all the fucking chats to-do list.
There's, this is not, this is your to-do list, guys.
It's not my to-do list.
If you're gonna, I'm gonna put slow-mo on Twitch.
This is, uh-oh.
Did you, thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
No, thank you.
This is your to-do list.
I have my list on my left side.
My list is on the left side.
Your list is on the right side.
And also, also, if you guys are like, if we can also ban
people.
If we ban people on Twitch, then like all the tasks get
removed instantly.
So like, there's also that option.
So if it's...
easier 30 minutes slow mo okay guys maybe not 30 okay okay
this is there's a lot of tasks coming 109 chat anyway um
anyway uh i was really excited to try this new widget out uh
i is from Who is it say say a nani?
Because I've been like following her stuff like this like
the stuff she develops On like widget for which streamer
widget, but it only works on Twitch.
I mean, I could invite I wonder if I could invite stream
elements I was thinking about inviting stream elements into
YouTube Because it's like a stream elements widget But then
I was like I didn't want to clutter up my own chat like on
the YouTube chat So like I figured it's like I was like also
partially inspired by Ame, like remember her, her music bot,
where like she's when she used to do like those like streams
where you can listen to music by suggesting music on Twitch
and stuff like that.
So it like inspired me to do something similar to separate,
separate like, you know, the task list on Twitch so it
doesn't clutter up the yeah, Bumabot.
Yeah, so it doesn't clutter up the YouTube chat.
So that's why I decided to because like I think you can
invite stream elements to YouTube chat It'll do the same
thing, but I figured like, okay, I don't want my chat to
just be filled with fucking stupid things that are not
relevant to the task, because I know you guys were going to
troll with that.
I knew you guys were going to troll with a fucking command
list, so I figured I'm going to separate this to the Twitch
chat, so you can suggest stuff over there, and then my
YouTube chat, at least people can still be chatting on the
YouTube chat.
But I think it's so cool though.
Isn't it cool?
So like I can do like I can complete my tasks too.
Like I thought it was so cool.
That like you know like we can like work in real time.
Like my stuff on the left side.
Your stuff on the right side.
Two out of 154.
You guys are like 1% complete.
Let's race guys.
Let's see who can get their stuff done first.
Let's see who has like a higher percentage of complete.
their tasks guys oh my god i wonder who will win whoa
we were set up you guys did this to yourself hey guys thank
you the super chat thank you thank you you know us so well
love you too what's the difference between done and complete
is the same thing so you can use done or complete um it's
people who like you know want to type one want a shorter
word you just do exclamation point done and I hope you
remember what you wrote like I hope I hope you remember what
you fucking wrote guys I'm wondering if there's like another
thing you can type let me double check let's see settings uh
commands to do complete yeah complete and done on the same
thing I hope you guys remember because I don't know.
I think if you do.
Oh, you do delete.
Maybe if you do delete and then your username.
I think it's like delete.
And then your username on Twitch.
It deletes all the tasks for your entire, like all the tasks
that you put on there.
I think.
Guys, I'm learning this as I go.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, no, this is mod only.
Never mind.
Only mods can do that.
So, like, I hope you remember.
Never mind.
It says mod only commands.
JK, you guys better remember what you wrote.
Okay.
Mod, you're only deleting the ones that are useless.
That are obviously trolls.
Okay.
so yeah i mean if you don't remember then you're failing the
rest of the dragoons because you're like uh because
technically i'm winning the moment i finish one of my tasks
i basically win the race because i i don't know one out of a
hundred seven out of a hundred and eighty four i don't know
guys i don't fucking know uh thank you the super chat i'll
tell you mercy thank you thank you by racing against doki
answering dms we can literally never lose Thank you for the
super chat.
Thank you.
Um, anyway, you know, I'm giving you guys a head start
because I want to do a little Zatzadon.
Uh, last week was a full-on Tekken week plus Sunday.
And, um, we didn't really have a time to actually, like,
hang out and chat.
Like, it was just Tekken, Tekken, Tekken, Tekken.
And, uh, honestly, I'm like...
Super, oh my gosh.
I was like, what is that sound?
What's that?
Ah, sound.
I don't think you guys hear.
I don't think you guys hear it, but it was like, oh, it's
the task complete sound.
So every time you guys complete a task, there's like a
little pencil sound effect and like, it like catches me off
guard.
I was like, is that my music?
Like, uh, but yes, the Tekken arc.
Uh, and it was like, oh my gosh.
I'm like, I'm like, so tired from the time i was like i
think like right after the tournament i was like oh my gosh
i was so tired and like mentally exhausted because my social
battery was like gone basically because it was like uh with
paying out with like uh five five people and then like for
six plus hours almost every day so my social battery as an
introvert my social battery is like depleted now i think I
think I slept yesterday I basically slept like I think like
Oh my gosh I slept the whole day I woke up I woke up and
then And then like And then I think I was only away for like
Two to three hours and then I went back to sleep I was so
tired I was like oh my gosh I gotta get work done I'm so
behind because of Tekken And then so I started getting work
done And then I think like two to three hours I went back to
sleep and then I woke up at 11 p.m I woke up at 11 p.m.
And I was like, oh, fuck, I have so much work to do.
But then I got distracted and only did one hour at work.
And I actually got back to work at like 3 a.m.
And started, you know, that's why I posted my schedule at
like 4 in the morning.
Because, you know, I've been awake for, I've only been awake
for like 1% of the day.
managed to get my schedule done at 4 in the morning um but
i'm very behind i am very very behind on a lot of things at
the moment because of techin and uh and just like like
burying myself with training for techin yeah but it was a it
was a great time honestly i'm so happy i said yes to doing
the say jam slam it was a great experience and i made so
many new friends uh i really love team brawl pro uh they're
great to hang out with and honestly like um never expected
to win first place that's for sure the biggest upset in
history when i when i beat sk no one like i think like only
like five percent believed in me in the say jam because
there was like a betting pool uh there was a betting pool
apparently during like the me versus sk match and it was
like 300k versus 1.5 million i was like i was literally the
like it was like a david versus goliath situation nobody
expected me to win
it was actually fucking crazy
and um I'm really happy that like I honestly never expected
to win first I was like oh man like because I know my team
was really really good in general um because you know this
was like the same team in the first say jam slam and we
literally have Jack Jesus who like only lost one game in the
entire say jam slam um and uh I uh I I expected second but
not first because I feel like first Heavily relied on me
winning at least one game Like that's what that's what first
was like I just literally didn't win one game And I was like
oh, I don't know about this I I was like, I don't know it's
SK And I don't think even my team expected me to win that
one game.
I think my team was just like, okay, let's just make sure
she's not sad when she loses.
I feel like they were just like, all right, let's just make
sure she's not sad and that she's having a good time.
uh yeah nobody expected it but it was so uh uh it was just
insane that that happened i just realized my lure is like
not it's sorry my lure is uh not showing up because it's
getting covered let me put that here uh anyway but insane
experience i told us i told sayjam that like uh because like
Apparently the next Say Jam Slam is going to be Street
Fighter.
And I hope I get invited to the Street Fighter one.
Because I honestly had a great time.
And then like a lot of the...
Everybody in Team Brawl Pro wants to run it back again for
the next Say Jam Slam.
So yeah, it's for Street Fighter 6.
So I honestly hope I get invited for the next one.
And be also be placed back in Team Brawl Pro.
I don't know.
Like I don't like people like, oh why don't you want to
like, you know, be in a new team.
or i i just i just i just really like team brawl pro it's
just vibes you know i feel like i feel like there if i was
in any other team um the chemistry would not be the same i
don't know i just feel like it wouldn't be as fun if um it
was it was like with any other like combination i feel like
It was just the perfect...
I feel like the team was just the perfect combination.
And I hope...
I asked Seijam.
I was like, oh, if possible.
I told him if possible, I'd love to be invited again for the
Street Fight for the next Seijam Slam.
So I hope I get in.
I hope I get into the next one.
Because it was definitely really, really, really fun.
Apparently, I converted a lot of non-VTuber fans into
watching me now.
Because I was so fucking ridiculous.
Because I was unfiltered as fuck And I'm sorry that this is
the first stream you're coming into Where I'm like a bit
more chill right now Because I am so behind on a lot of
things If you're expecting more of what I was like During
the Tekken arc today I am so sorry I am so busy I'm so, I am
so behind.
So, like, originally I wasn't going to stream today.
I wasn't going to stream today because of how busy I was.
But I was like, man, I haven't had time to actually, you
know, talk to you guys and hang out with my chat.
Because when I do, like, collabs, I know, like, a lot of,
like, people who are used to watching, like, Fleshies.
do like push to talk where they would like you know talk to
the group and then like talk to the chat and do push to talk
i don't do push to talk maybe it's not a fleshy thing to do
i'm just lazy
i'm just i'm just lazy as well uh you have to stop but they
are fleshy they call me 2d
Anyway, um, uh, as I was saying, um, usually I, the only
time I'd like mute myself to talk to my chat is if there was
like intermission time, which there was during some moments
in Tekken where we had to wait for a game.
So that's when I like, you know, muted myself to talk to you
guys.
But usually in collabs, I try to give like full focus on
like, you know, talking to the people I'm hanging out with
or the people, um, oh, sorry, I met them.
meatbags.
Thank you for the 20 gifted chefs.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Sage, thank you.
Thank you.
More distractions.
Yippee.
Thank you.
Super chat.
It's giving you guys a head start.
You guys definitely need it.
All I'm saying that you need the head start because the
moment i finish one task like this race is over like this
race is so over come on chat we're already at 25 but guys
you can literally add more like some some fucker can like
several fuckers can literally just add more tasks for you
guys and ruin your your race like this is rigged there's
slow mode slow mode is actually helping you guys.
I don't know.
Anyway, I mean, the mod can easily put it back.
Put the slow mode to 10 minutes.
Put the slow mode to 10 minutes, not 30 minutes.
Like, give them that, I guess.
Um, anyway, but yes, uh, it is like, oh my god, it doesn't
stop.
Oh my god, it just keeps going.
um uh where was that um uh oh yes but yes a lot of new we
have a lot of new viewers uh that came from Tekken because
of the shit I like the shit I say when I open my mouth uh
but yes welcome welcome new dragons uh usually you know we
usually have like other types of streams not this Like I
said, today I wasn't supposed to be streaming because of how
behind I was on, like, everything, like, in life.
So I figured, you know what, let's just, you know, be able
to, let's just, like, stream our work right now.
Well, I won't be showing you guys what the fuck I'm working
on, but, like, you know, be able to stream for you guys,
talk to you guys while we're working as well.
And also make you guys be productive as well.
So yeah, and I always wanted to try this widget out like
this I feel like it's it's nice because we can all just like
be productive together and like all both of like all put
both of us me and that one Dragoon Me and my one Dragoon and
his like 2000 bots accounts
on finishing stuff up.
Ultima, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Congratulations on the tournament, Doki.
You're awesome.
New Found here.
Thank you.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
I'm glad you guys really enjoyed the tournament arc.
So, like, what else?
Oh, yes.
As you can see, this week is also pretty fucking packed.
I got invited to, you guys can see there's also an Apex
tournament that's happening on the same day as WrestleTuber.
So, like, I got invited to a vtuber what it says vtuber but
then there's like non vtuber's in there there's like there's
like maybe like i think like two or three non-vtuber's in
there um but anyway there is like a vtuber like apex
invitational that's much mostly na and then like usually
like i haven't really participated i don't know you noticed
this but in the past invited to like uh like like vtuber
invitations in like na parts of the world um so i've because
like i've been invited to like more i guess like pro
tournaments um like pro tournaments uh with like you know na
pros and stuff like that but not like vtuber apex
invitational so i figured like and i looked at the list i
was like oh hey there's like some people here that are like
you know well known in the like apex v i think it's also
because there's not a lot of like well known apex uh vtuber
vtuber uh streamers in general i mean to be fair i'm barely
an apex vtuber streamer
i'm barely one as well like i'm just variety now um so um so
like i figured like um like they invited me but then I saw
that it's sort of like conflict it comes I didn't like when
they invited me I couldn't tell them why like I was just
like oh I don't know God like I couldn't say like
WrestleTuber because it wasn't announced yet so that was
like oh it sort of conflicts with WrestleTuber because like
my thing starts at four and like I can't move the date and
time because like there's a lot of people participating so
then like the organizers there was like oh we'll move our
our tournament and I felt bad because they're like because
they moved the me so like they moved the the day the time
for it like an hour earlier for me so then i was like oh
okay i was like oh okay that's that's really sweet okay so
then i was like all right yeah i could i could do it as long
as i have like time to uh as long as like because i was like
oh by the time it ends, I have to I have to like do the do
WrestleTuber because originally they said it's going to end
at 4 and I was like, oh, I can't, I can't do that I
literally have to do something at 4 and it's like this whole
event that I'm organizing.
I couldn't say what event it was.
So then they were like, oh we'll do it, we'll have the
tournament like an hour earlier.
And I was like, oh okay.
And then because they you know They said they'll have the
tournament now earlier.
I was like, oh, yeah, okay, I'll join.
Like, because then, like, they moved the tournament.
So I was just like, oh, fuck.
Yeah, I'll join.
And, um, and so, and like, I felt like I never really had a
chance to join a, in, like, like I said, like, all the other
Apex YouTuber invitational stuff.
I've never really been like, um, invited to to it like as a
captain um um i like i think like the last vtuber
invitational that happened uh i was like someone got invited
and then they invited me to be on their team but then like
the captain had to drop out at the last sec uh at the last
minute do the scheduling thing but then i didn't realize so
i thought i was gonna be part of it but then like because
they dropped The team, like, I think it was, like, a
miscommunication thing because they're like, oh, because it
was supposed to be, like, we find a replacement for the
captain.
But then, like, it was a miscommunication that they ended up
giving the team spot to a different team.
So then, like, I couldn't join.
So it was, like, I was really sad about that.
So, like, I never had a chance to ever do a V-Tuber
invitational for Apex in, like, N.A.
And I was like, okay, like, like, when I first got that,
like, the invite I was like really happy because I've never
been invited before as a captain so you know and I was like
oh I'm sad so I was super super happy that like like I got
invited um to like to like one with like all the known like
apex vtubers like not just NA it's also EU because I know
like There's like, like, I mean, I got RPR in it, so it's
not just NA, but there's like, um, but like, you know, like
English, I guess like English speaking, English speaking
Apex VTubers.
I feel like that's the better term for it.
Apex, sorry, English speaking, um, uh, Apex VTubers.
Uh, so I'm really happy.
Anyway, I dragged RPR and did a, to it.
We have our first Scrim tomorrow.
Apparently, we've been having Scrims for a while.
But, like, I was literally so busy.
I couldn't join any of the Scrims.
So, like, and there's, like, cash prizes for the Scrims.
So, I think, I mean, it's, like, $150 if we win, I think,
divided by three people.
So, like, you know, $50 each.
If we win the first, if we win the Scrim.
But, yes, Wednesday is the, tomorrow is the first Scrim.
you guys can see i got invited to the uh to a um uh billy
billy uh arc server uh v2 billy vtuber arc server but i'll
be streaming it on youtube because i don't have a billy
billy account yet um hirro invited me to it um she asked me
i wanted to check it out and there's gonna be like know and
you know like this is not like the first time there's been
like an arc server like a vtuber arc server but in the past
i would i i think i i think you guys know i talked about it
before because i know like you guys would be like why didn't
you join like why don't you join this arc server uh blah
blah blah and i i think i talked about it before where the
reason why i never joined the like arc servers in the past
um is because uh of language barriers and uh Because like,
you know, I didn't I felt like I wouldn't enjoy it as much
due to the language barriers going in and I wouldn't because
like the whole thing about it is like being able to
communicate with other people on the server.
Like, I mean, you know, if I can't speak the language, like
I feel like it wouldn't be as fun, especially when like, you
know, the majority about this is like the roleplay and like
I don't want to force people to speak English, you know?
like in this one I can understand Chinese so I can like at
least like speak sort of speak it I can like understand and
listen to it so like at least I can like contribute
at least I can like contribute to the conversation
that's why I said yes to I said yes to like joining uh to
joining the server so I'm really excited um huge shout out
to Hiro for giving me an invite uh to the server um what
else I think that's really it in regards to I mean I wrote
some stuff down like what do I want to update my chat with
let's see I like how I'm looking at my server my discord
server where I write like notes and stuff and all of it is
just like tech uh down l2 forward forward two go for grab
instead of instant heat smash drawing heat do tomahawk
instead of instant heat running three then r3 like i'm just
a server is just like notes of stuff to do and fucking deck
it forward three row running down back two three
it's just it didn't crack It's just slowly adding more tasks
guys.
It didn't fucking crash chat It's just a lot of stuff being
added to it But yeah, that's the life update I might have
more life updates, but I honestly forgot what to say There's
so many things happening.
Oh, yeah, I'm so excited for next week's schedule.
I know like this week's schedule is like barely like it's
just begun technically but like next week is so exciting i
oh my god next week is gonna be so fun i cannot wait for
next week ah i wish i could just fast forward i'm super
nervous about wrestletuber i am really really nervous no
spoilers no spoilers you'll see you'll know you'll know when
you see the schedule guys um no spoilers you'll know when
you see the schedule it's gonna be well for me i'm gonna be
having fun like for me it's gonna be a good time i'm not
gonna overhype it i'm just saying i'm gonna have a good time
um just gotta wait until anticipation um also i noticed
people were like is the anime north panel gonna be streamed
no it's an in-person event like um you have to be there well
i'll be digitally i'll be there digitally because i'm not
real but like um you have to be at anime north to like go to
that panel that'll be my first time doing a solo panel i've
never done a solo panel before apparently there's gonna be
like a moderator there so i can like talk to that's gonna
like meet what's it called a mediator fuck i don't know what
it's called the person that like tries to make sure
everything goes well
um um and like i'm not sure yet if you can like give me
gifts yet i should have asked i think you can mediate yeah
is a mediator yeah so i think you can like give me gifts and
stuff and then they'll ship it over um but like let me i
need to make sure i need to ask like confirmation i won't be
accepting anything like uh i won't be accepting obviously
food i will not be accepting food i would not be accepting
like um electronics i would not be like i'll not be
accepting electronics i'll not be accepting like um i don't
think i'll be accepting like um i guess like retail plushies
like i guess if it's like handmade or something like i don't
know i don't know what the rules are but like if we are
accepting gifts um um those are like my personal rules just
to make sure like you know will you accept real cash no
because the post office is gonna steal it like this is why
we don't send you know in back in the day before paypal was
a thing people will literally send cash you guys remember
that right like back okay no some of you guys are way too
young but back in the day people will actually like um Put
cash in their envelopes because PayPal wasn't a thing yet,
which I, it always surprises me that fucking Elon Musk owns
PayPal.
Anyway, great choice.
Thank you for the file.
Give the ships.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
And her name is John Doe King.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Send in cash.
No, it's not.
People used to put actual real dollar bills.
in like envelopes and just send it over and then like um the
post office would uh oh he doesn't own paypal anymore didn't
he used to he got okay yeah that that seems like something
that would happen he was when did he get kicked out oh my
god oh yeah i remember because he wanted to call it x I
remember now he tried to call like PayPal X and then PayPal
was like bro that's what I remembered yeah because people
were like bro this is not the first time he tried to rename
a fucking website to X is not stupid yeah I remember now
that's why I knew that fun fact Oh my gosh, it's so fun.
What a fun fact, Chet.
Friend, thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Do you still accept Supers?
Of course I do.
What the fuck?
Thank you.
I like money.
Okay, like, you can't be like, wow, dokie.
Shameless much.
Guys.
Don't lie, you all like money.
you can't fucking judge me all of you like money it's like
saying if you like breathing um thank you for the akasupa
thank you thank you um i hate oh you hate money oh man if
only there was a way to give away that money that you hate
so much to somebody that likes money ah what can what guys
what do you think what kind of solutions can we offer to
that one person that hates money so much if only there was
such a simple easy way with just two presses of buttons that
would send all that hate money over
charity middle name is charity it's a doki charity bird uh
mr broken bond thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you
i don't like money here take it money love it thank you for
the akasupa thank you thank you man thank you for the
magenta soup but they can thank you uh man i hate money too
uh next see thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you
here doki i hate money you can have I'm mine.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Alex, thank you for the 50 gifted ships.
Thank you, guys.
I really, I really, damn, so many money haters.
What a shame.
Oh my gosh.
What was I saying before?
I got so distracted.
Uh, I got so distracted.
What was I talking?
about before before before it's the one the infinite money
glitch
uh oh yeah yeah the uh anime north but yes uh um but yes it
is uh an in-person thing it's not gonna be streamed or
anything the panel so you guys have to be there to be to to
you know to see what the fuck the panel is gonna be i think
it's just a q a um it's gonna be a q a a session uh so uh
basically you go there ask me questions and we hang out it's
like a stream but like you're there it's like an exclusive
stream oh yeah it's like a member stream but more exclusive
i think that's like the best way i can explain it honestly
um
huh what it's true though it's true True, I feel like that,
that's like basically what panels are.
It's just like a member stream, but like it's a more, it's
more exclusive.
Um, I remember like, oh my gosh, I remember when like Anime
North was like, oh hey, we're gonna have to like, um, they
were like, oh, we're gonna have to like cap.
They're like, oh sorry, but only like X amount of dragoons
can like be in the panel room.
And I was like, that's, that's a lie.
I don't remember.
I think it was like 200.
Let me look at what they said.
I remember it.
And I was like, oh my God.
They're like, oh yeah, I hope you're okay.
We like make, like if not everybody can be there, like can
like be in the room because like it's a fire hazard.
I was like, bro, that's a lie.
Let me see what I said.
And I felt so embarrassed because I was just like, oh man,
like that's I don't know I don't know if like we'll even
have that many people there let me see uh oh my gosh I want
to see like what I wrote because it's sort of a little
embarrassing because like I felt I felt so bad when I said
that um let me see I can find it uh oh my gosh is it the
same person Oh my gosh.
Maybe this is for a different one.
Let me see if I can find it.
Wait, is this the same person?
Or was it for a different convention?
There's so many conventions, guys.
There's...
Fuck.
Okay, I need to find it.
Let's see.
I wish I wrote... Oh, no.
I don't know where it was.
I guess this wasn't the same person.
I think it was 200.
I think it was, I don't remember, but it could have been a
different person I was talking to.
no, it has to be Anime North.
Unless she knows it was Narc.
No, okay, it has to be.
Uh, but anyway, they're like, are you, is it okay if, like,
uh, if, like, we have to, like, turn some Dragoon, like, we
might have to, like, have a hard cap of how many Dragoons
are allowed in the room.
And I was like, oh, that's fine.
I don't think we're gonna fucking fill that up.
I was just I was just like I think that's fine I don't think
we're gonna I don't think we're gonna fill up the room I was
just like And then they're like Oh we have a lot of And then
they're I don't know I was like I don't know I don't know
how many dragoons are gonna be in Toronto
I I don't know.
So then they're like, oh, bro, they're like, no, we had this
other VTuber and we had to have hard cap in.
We actually get like a lot of people at a convention.
I was like, oh, I'm sorry.
I was like, I'm so sorry.
I didn't know.
I don't know.
Okay, to be fair, in the previous panels, I never really
know how many people are actually.
I mean, I could see
head i'm just like oh yeah oh here we go okay it's 600.
they're like the room seats 600 people and it's a pretty
hard cap from the fire marshal and they're like oh and going
by like shy lily like the crowd will be completely full and
i'll just be like i'll be surprised if i get 600
i just be like i'll be so surprised I told him that I was
like no way
And they're like And they're like oh we've had like a
thousand plus They're like they're like anyway And then the
organizer was like okay We're just gonna pretend you're
gonna get like a thousand plus people lining up Just in case
They're like we're not gonna like Not plan for this because
I was like Oh I think it'll be fine I was literally like,
no, I think, I don't think you have to worry, like, about
the line.
And they're like, and then the organizer was like, we're
just gonna assume that we'll be prepared for, like, if a lot
of people line up.
And they're like, they're like, Doki, this convention has
37,000 people attending every year.
And I was just like, oh, that's a lot.
that's a lot of people that is that is a lot of people
um so yeah i mean i'll still be surprised i i really i will
be very surprised because like i'm just one person that's
why i was like i was like i'm just one person so like i
don't know if we I'll be very surprised, but I really
appreciate it, Jack.
I really, I really appreciate it if you guys actually fill
up the room.
It'll be a blast.
We're going to party.
We're going to have so much fun.
Yeah, Anime North is the first, is the first, the first
convention in the Doki World Tour.
Yippee!
I'm sorry that we couldn't do a meet and greet because like
uh, Adam North was like super last minute, I think uh,
because we saw the email from Adam North, uh, very late.
Uh, so like we couldn't at that time they were, they were
like full on like, uh, guests and stuff, but they slid me
in, uh, last minute.
And because of that we were able to, uh, we were able to
like, uh, have a panel because it was like the only thing
that was like free i guess it was the only they couldn't
have they didn't have enough time to actually set up any
meeting greets and stuff like that only because they're like
it was like the last minute slip in for me but i'm happy to
be still be able to do like you know do a panel at that
convention i know i said i know guys you're like real tour
there's a lot of canadian look guys i've never had a chance
to do a canadian convention before and like you know as a
canadian as a canadian a vtuber like come on let me have
this the american goons had almost all the conventions guys
let the canadians have one not one but like maybe several
also um another update um yes i've been getting a lot of
emails regarding shipments of debut merch i'm really sorry
that's been taking a while um we were uh like negotiations
with the distributor is taking surprisingly longer than i
expected um so like currently the only orders that are going
out at the moment are the orders that i've personally
packaged and i think i've packaged like 200 orders myself so
like there's a lot of there's a lot of orders so i'm really
sorry i'm gonna post a twitter update at the moment uh so uh
like I won't be shy about like how many I'll let you guys
know there has been 6,000 plus merch orders not just from
debut but like for the lunar new year as well but the moment
we get the distributor thing the moment we get the
distributor thing finalized it will go out so fast it will
like bam bam bam bam so at the moment I am packaging it
myself when I do have the time because obviously I time is
not on my side
um so uh those lucky people some of you actually already
received the uh received the packages uh that have packaged
myself um but yes uh that's why I'm sorry that like the
orders are like like not as fast as i would have liked
that's why i haven't had any new merch drops there's been
plans for new merch drops like i've had like plans done for
it and i am holding on to a merch drop at the moment but i
told them i was like i'm not releasing any new merch until
we we have like until we start like officially not by me
like you know officially by distributor uh shipping these
uh because like i obviously want to get that i want to get
that situated before uh before like you know before
releasing anything new i would say i know i talked about
this before but like if i did have like regular merch going
in like if i was releasing regular merch like every like
fucking month there's a new merch or anything merch would
have basically made would be like 60 to 70 percent If I like
kept the merch stuff going like
Because like like merch is like it's such a huge like income
in general I didn't realize how big of a difference like
merch can be Until I started selling my own merch because
like the amount I was making off of merch when I released
the debut merch and the lunar new year was absolutely crazy
i was just like oh my i'm not i'm like i know i won't be
like i'm i'm gonna be transparent like i am making i can
make if i actually like kept releasing new merch drops i can
make a lot of money from it um but i want to get situated
first with the fact that i want to make sure that like
everybody is getting their merch like uh and they don't wait
it's not delayed too long and that's why i'm not releasing
anything new until uh until all of that is like fucking done
like until we have a system for it um and uh and that's why
like there's no new releases and stuff like I have okay to
be fair I actually have like I even have graphics made for
the next drop but like we're not releasing this until like
much much later I think like I showed it uh people in the
members might have seen it both seen it because I did show
it but I'll show you guys I'll show you guys what it is um
but it's basically uh uh it is basically the uh I was I was
planning on doing merch drop of the uh of the intro let me
see if I can fucking find it because like there's uh there's
no naming system for my shit there's no name oh here it is
Okay, um I think it's this Alright, so like This was gonna
be the next Merch drop That's gonna be like on hold Until
everything's Okay
People in the members have already seen it But like it was
basically like stickers and buttons were gonna be Gotcha
because like there was a lot
we have so it'll be like stuff like this so i mean the
stance you can like you can if you want to you can have it
all and create your own fucking dancing and dancing dokey
like stance where you could choose um you can choose which
one and then uh i think this one had no why is it and then
there was like there was like gotcha for the stickers
because there was more choices to it so like stickers were
gotcha so I could just like stick my hand in and be like
okay well when we have distributor the distributor was gonna
stick their hand
but like like I said we're not releasing that until we
fucking figure out Until like the distributor shit is like
finally situated and stuff.
The negotiations took, it's taking much longer.
Like I said, it's taking much longer than I expected.
Um, because like at first, um, I guess like the, like when
we were talking, the distributors who were talking to
multiple distributors, they were not prepared for the amount
of orders I was going to get.
So the negotiations were taking much longer because when
we're telling them like, yeah these are like the amount of
pre-orders we're getting they're like whoa
that's that's a lot more than we expected
i really appreciate it jagoons for like the huge amount of
support uh the huge amount of support from uh for the merch
in general and And I really appreciate your patience because
we have been getting a lot of emails because I know I did
say like, you know, like around this time things were being
sent out and it hasn't been sent out yet.
It's just that I'll be doing a Twitter and the community
post update for it later because I've been waiting.
I've been waiting to see if we finalize the negotiations.
But obviously we haven't.
So I know we've been getting a lot of emails about it every
day about like, oh, when?
is the order coming in um but i'll uh i'm gonna keep you
guys updated uh and like i'm gonna put out twitter update
about it as well um but yeah it's actually crazy thank you
guys so much like uh honestly like if um i just kept going
with the merch drops like it's a huge i think like obviously
now it's not really a big like not a big part of my income
at the moment but definitely If I, like, when, if I, like,
kept the rate of doing merch drops, if I, you know, if I
had, like, merch drops every other month or every month,
that could have easily been, like, 60 to 70% of my income if
I kept at it.
Like, I, I'm going to be super transparent with you guys.
That is literally, that is, like, that could be 60 to 70% of
my income if I kept at it, like, every month or every other
month.
but i decided not to because ethically like morally i was
like i need to figure out this shit first um our voice packs
on help yeah we're planning on voice packs later on in the
future um i just didn't have a time like we haven't hired a
script we have had resumes for script writers and stuff i'm
planning on hiring more people for my team as well because
like uh i definitely want expand the doki team more uh so
that we have people that are responsible because like at the
moment merch design and like merch stuff is mostly from me
like coming up with these things but definitely in the
future i'm looking to definitely have like hire like like a
person or a team that's dedicated to like designing new
merch and stuff and not designing you i guess not designing
new merch but like figuring out the merch system
yeah yeah like because a lot of stuff I am doing by myself
mostly oh my god also you guys want to see the new wrestling
belt I know like I gave you guys such a huge head start guys
I know and you're still at 18% guys you're still at yes
you're still I gave you guys like one hour of a head start
and you're still at 18 percent anyway let me show you guys
the um oh my gosh i'm so looking forward to like um the new
belt the new belt looks so fucking cool uh the artist just
sent me like a draft of it i mean this is just like the logo
and stuff like just like the logos being done uh but it's
not like the belt belt itself but it's like the logos and
stuff and i think it looks really good look at this look at
this oh my gosh oh i'm also like the belt uh because like
gamer subs is paying for it and the belt that they they
chose is like high quality as shit it's like 300 belt i just
want to say because like it's actually like what's the word
like there's like it's like bump like what's the word like
it like actually pops out like the like like oh what's uh
the metal is actually popping out type deal it's not like a
printed thing there's like actual texture um is it embossed
it's like is like that's how it's called in great embossed
um but like the metal actually pop out and stuff it's not
like a printed metal or anything they like chose like they
wanted to do like the the um um the one where it can like
it's not like stamped or anything is actually popping out um
but it's so cool like like they showed me like what were
they ordering it from and it's like much like to compare the
last belt i ordered was like a hundred dollars like a belt
they want to order is 300
like that's the that's the difference like so um super uh um
i'm super duper excited uh for everything but yeah those are
like some of the updates going on um uh but i am super duper
excited like i said i'm really thank you guys again for like
being patient with the merch stuff i don't mind being
transparent because i know like people are like oh why are
you letting leaking out like how much you sold and stuff
like i i don't who's gonna fucking like yell at me i'm
literally the ceo
who's gonna yell at me i'm the boss
who cares if you guys know how many i sold because you know
i put all my income back into my own channel anyway
like all my income goes back to my own channel anyway who
fuck cares like oh yeah also minecraft update um let's see
uh oh yeah i know like some of you guys are like when's the
minecraft server i'm so sorry it's taking so long uh we like
hit some uh bumps in the road because like i was also really
busy and they needed like they needed me to like uh figure
out like colors and stuff of like how the server looks like
so like um okay let me show you like a before and after uh
we will redecorate this later okay i know like the colors
right now they might not be like the best um um anyway so
like uh do we have like some because like okay this was the
original color for the main hub we're gonna change the main
hub later because at first like I want to give you guys
more, like, okay, sorry, for those, for those who don't
know, we're starting a members Dragoon Minecraft server,
but, like, I'll be streaming the server publicly because you
can't, like, you can put the server, like, joining the
server behind a paywall, but you can't stream Minecraft
behind a paywall.
But, like, I know, like, it's been in the works because
there's been, like, a lot of stuff going on.
But like this was the original concept for the lobby, but
that was like that's just too brown I was like oh my gosh,
it's just brown And then we're gonna also later on when we
actually have people in the lobby So then we like put more
color into it like and so it looks like this now I know it
looks weird
I know there's like a lot of colors But like I said, this is
just a main lobby It is just a It's just a main lobby for
now So like obviously you all spawn in here All you guys
will spawn Like there's gonna be You guys will all spawn in
here So you can create better Like when you join your
faction You can create like You can create like better
builds if you want Later on, the main lobby will get
upgraded the more, like, the more we play.
Because, like, now they're like, what do you want?
And I'm like, I don't know.
They're like, Doki, what do you want for your main lobby?
And I'm like, I don't fucking know.
I don't know.
So they made this from, like, the notes I gave them, which
was, I don't know.
so this is i really appreciate it from um from like the
designers for making this based off of my notes which was no
notes in general so
so like i'm i that's why i was like i'm fine with this for
now because i think like later on when we like figure out
what we want the unique guy i don't know i don't know what
hop should look like like i've been i've been shooting for
like three months like what do i have we'll build on it more
later later it look different guys i swear it'll look
different later anyway anyway so you guys are like wondering
okay so like what do you mean by factions so like um so like
you can you have push a button and then you're going to be
taken to this island where uh you're going to be like
picking which faction you want to join um so obviously
there's like a goon the dragon and stuff like that so you
can pick your faction uh so obviously uh um uh the territory
will not be linked to your you also can claim your land so
like each person has like an amount of blocks they can claim
and uh like i said this is for members like to join a server
you have to be a member uh but we'll be streaming the server
on public streams like the the gameplay of this will be
streamed so obviously like you each get to have get to claim
land uh so you know the people won't be griefing each other
like you know if you leave your build can we invade people's
lands if they didn't claim it yeah you can there'll be like
pvp zones too we'll have like areas where you can fight if
you want to um so uh yes and then we'll have like like
resource areas as well uh so that's why like uh that's like
that's basically what it's gonna be like uh so that's an
update on the minecraft stuff anyway I'll give you guys an
hour and 15 minutes of a head start.
Let me finish one task and win this race, guys.
Like, that's literally all I have to do.
I just need to finish one fucking task.
That's all.
I hell no.
I guess they're not making this much of a competition right
now.
Only, like, really?
I gave you guys an hour and 30 minutes.
50, 20, almost an hour, 20 minutes.
And you're only up to 20.
2%?
Not even 25?
This is great.
Don't let her win.
I don't know, guys.
To be fair, you guys aren't even helping each other.
Because, like, you're adding more stuff to it in the way
that, like, you're sabotaging yourself.
So, like...
It really only takes several dragoons to fuck over
everybody.
I, like, just got here.
It's like, bro, there's the backfiller.
Buster, the backfiller there.
He just got here and he already lost.
Hmm.
All right.
Rigged.
Why?
All right.
You guys got better remember what you fucking wrote, too.
Time to work, guys.
chatting is actually time to work, guys.
I sat down for, like, an hour and 30 minutes in his workday.
Usually, okay, guys, do you think it's worth the risk to
listen to, like, Disney jazz?
Do you think...
We don't need a monetize.
It's a chatting stream.
Fuck it.
I know, like, it's lo-fi, but, like, I don't care.
I usually listen to Disney jazz to help work.
Okay, Disney jazz.
No!
Dude.
what it is.
I just lose ad revenue.
Who cares?
It's just ad revenue.
They just fucking, oh no, my fucking five dollars.
They can't.
Okay, all right.
If it's not, okay, Studio Ghibli might be a little bit more
ambitious, though, to be fair, because it's Japan.
So, Studio Ghibli Cafe Jazz.
All right, Wakata Jazz, that's like less Disney and Studio
Jibli.
All right, let's play for fire.
Let's get Japan and Disney involved.
Let's fucking go.
Japan and Disney involved.
No, that's...
Bro, oh my god, is there Studio Jibli, Nintendo, and Disney
Jazz?
Okay, Jibli, Nintendo, Disney, Jazz.
Let's put all three in there.
We might as well.
You're right.
We got to throw in some Nintendo.
All right, let's see.
All right, I got you guys.
We're going to put, like, Nintendo.
Oh, my gosh.
Let's start out with, like, the Animal Crossing, Jazz.
Is this Animal Crossing?
Yeah.
All right, let's start it off.
Someone stop.
all right we're gonna do studio jibbly nintendo and uh and
disney all in one let's go might as well i mean we might as
well commit you know like if we're gonna we're gonna go this
route we commit to it uh cas doki demonetize speed run any
percent thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
Nothing can stop me.
No, I think I rather go with the jazz first, actually.
There we go.
That's fine.
We'll be fine.
It's jazz!
Everybody loves jazz.
All right.
Let's work.
What do I have to do?
Answer...
Okay, ask your Discord DMs.
Let's see.
I'll answer my Discord DMs first.
Okay.
Can your friends do this?
Can your friends do that?
Put your little hat.
I don't think you guys should cheer for 25%.
I literally have to do one task, guys.
Taurus, they give the 10 gift of ships, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah, we're going to be making a highlight video for the
Seijam Slam.
So if you guys couldn't catch, like, you know, three fucking
vibes, are like five plus hours each we will we will have a
highlights video being made i don't know when it's gonna be
uploaded though
i hope you guys are being productive too chat oh yeah i
didn't get joined the anime north discord forgot about that
yay almost forgot to join anime north discord
the music to be louder?
Or is it fine?
Defying productive?
Yeah, help your fellow dragoons out!
You've only completed 68% like, no, 60.
68 out of 263.
I can move it, put it a little bit higher.
Is it better now?
what
the fuck does someone get heirloom from apex pack oh my god
you want the dragoons to fail like where it is fucking
impossible task someone was like add get heirloom from an
apex pack
sabotage so mod delete that one please please please delete
this the dragons are banging okay i'm not deleting that
because it's feasible
so they can get their heirloom.
I like how Din Viesel was like, do one push-up.
Done.
Did one push-up.
Someone didn't give Din Viesel a medal.
He did one push-up.
Ten minute push-up.
Oh, you guys see that?
There he is.
Get heirloom from Apex.
It showed up on the to-do list.
Guys, it's there!
Now you know who to blame.
Boy, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm so hyped for one day to see you open up that Minecraft
PvP server.
I waited on this for years.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Me too.
I'm really happy to be able to open that soon.
Super excited.
I'm pretty sure you guys are gonna be so creative and like I
want to build more onto that server and maybe host like Some
minecraft events in that server too for like community
events too in the future Because I have like an actual
minecraft team that can like they work on like they the team
that hired to do the server Um They've worked for like
twitch and stuff for like minecraft twitch rivals So they're
able to develop like actual like events and stuff for us in
the future Like, member events.
So, like, we're obviously going to build up more and more of
it.
And, like, it's not just going to be, like, something I'm
just going to let it die.
I'm going to make sure that we can improve it more and more.
And there's always going to be players on it, too.
There's always going to be people on the server.
And it's always going to be fun.
And if, like, I might have, I want in the future to
implement a system.
like um uh if like i feel like if x amount of maybe like if
more than they haven't been back to server after like you
know like three to four months or something um their builds
like the p like their builds won't be protected so that if
like you know obviously people come and go um i think in the
future i'm not sure like i'm not sure like the time frame
but i don't want to be just make it the server so that like
new people can't come in and the new people can't come in
and have nowhere else to build so i want like in the future
um uh if there's like like deserted builds or stuff like
that there's like a way to like uh what's the word uh
there's a way to make sure like new players can still can
join in and um and have like somewhere to build
he went silly and dumb minecraft But the actual Minecraft
drama?
We do not want to be involved in any Minecraft drama.
In any real Minecraft drama.
That shit is off limits.
There is Minecraft.
Yes.
Just like in Smash.
Because the Minecraft...
I'm sorry.
But like...
The Minecraft is...
smash communities are predominantly children and because of
that it is not a fun time
you don't you don't want to be near that shit
it's because a lot of people get popular I'm gonna say it
I'm gonna say it it's not really I don't think I don't think
it's like a super I don't think it's like a like you know
hot topic thing to say but like um a lot of the people who
get popular really fast in minecraft they've never been okay
it's so fucked up they've never peaked before so like the
most intention they ever got was in minecraft was playing
Minecraft and majority of it are like, you know, they're
like, oh my god, look at all this attention that I'm
getting.
Nobody ever gave me that much attention before.
Oh my God, people actually, oh my God.
And then they're like, I have so much power.
And then they're like super young as well.
They're super young.
And that's the scary part when someone is like really young
and have like so much attention and money um and never
really like had consequences and it gets to their head real
quick yes um because like you know being like a millionaire
at like 18 is nothing okay not nothing but like having an 18
year old millionaire is scary because an 18 year old
millionaire would think wow when you give an 18 year old
that much money you don't you don't want to know what
they're gonna spend i feel like that rarely ends well and
that's the minecraft community
and and and that is the minecraft community sometimes
they're not even 18 sometimes they're 16 with million with
millions of dollars um but yes we don't want to be involved
in any minecraft drama oh and then the worst part is that
even when they have that drama all they have to do is just
wait a couple of months and then like they're fine it
doesn't matter because you might say the internet will
always remember but like children don't children will never
remember they're like but he's funny he's he's funny though
Not a majority.
Why bad when funny?
There are new children.
True.
There's new children take their place.
That's why the Minecraft community scares me.
I mean, like...
We can all see...
Like...
like like okay it's not really a huge like not like oh my
god joki you're not supposed to talk about it but like
easily the dream sm like the whole dream smp or whatever
like everybody that's part of the dream group got fucking
into some sort of controversy and they're okay like i think
there's it doesn't matter it's still okay like
What happened to that?
There's so many.
I remember like, because like, Agumi, like, knows about it.
Cause, like, she's, like, friends with, like, within, like,
the Minecraft community.
And then I got really confused.
Cause, like, she was like, oh my God.
Did you hear about what happened to this person?
And I was like, who?
And then she, like, explained it to me.
And I was like, who the fuck?
I didn't look it up.
I was like, one million followers.
I was like, oh, this guy is important.
it and then and then they're like yeah there's a whole shit
going on right now
and then like i look back i think like recently i checked up
on it and then like they're still okay like people forgot or
not forgot but like minecraft
oh how many fucking controversies has dream got into so far
like it never stops i feel like every two to three months i
hear something new about dream that i don't want to hear
about but he's still making millions of dollars
a lot like you can't even like list any that's what i'm
saying the internet will like the okay maybe like minecraft
portion like they'll just oh my god there was one else so
okay i swear minecraft drama i can't even talk about this
drama because there's like so many fucking ones that I like
just read up that just like uh showed up there's like some
fucking crazy ones that are actually insane I was like how
the how the fuck how is that how did that how was that
possible and then they still have like I don't understand
that's what I'm saying They'll still have a fan base because
children are like...
But he funny.
Lay, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doki, I can't watch much right now, but I'm dropping by
a super because it's my birthday!
I enjoy watching your streams a lot.
Continue to be amazing and have a nice day there.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Lay, happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear.
A happy birthday to you.
But he funny and pretty.
True.
So true.
That man's gonna be my future husband.
He cannot do.
He can do no wrong.
It's like the ones.
It honestly reminds me of like, it when like uh like
handsome murderers are on trial and then the women are and
then there's like women and and i guess like gay men are
like oh my god but he's so hot though i can fix him
apparently i don't guys notice but like um there was like
what was his name um oh my god like I guess dead wait is he
who is the one that was had a call that had like a fucking
murder call was it Ted Bundy okay do you know like Ted was
it Ted who was the one yeah Ted or was it Manson which one
had okay there were so many murder cults like Charles Manson
did you know he had like several prison wives prison for
murder you know for the murder cult but then like several
like women outside of prison would send him like mail up and
then like he got married to several women while he was in
prison because the women outside of prison was like although
he murdered a lot of people but like he's hot though
You guys didn't know that?
He literally had like wise like he had wise while in prison
because so many like women sent him like mail like literally
wrote mail to him as like a pen pal stuff.
Like it's not like they were in prison with him.
It was like they were outside of prison, you know, regular
people.
I don't know if you can say regular because they're fucking
like married to fucking Charles Manson.
Like,
alright, like, I guess you're not normal anymore after
you're trying to fucking marry Charles Manson, the little
leader of a murder cult.
Like, oh yeah, I guess like Ted Bundy, too.
Yeah, sorry.
Ted Bundy and Charles Manson.
Um, but, like, they literally had, like, wives while, like,
not even, like, singular.
wife wife not even a singular wife it's wives and then like
um and like it was very public with all the stuff they
actually did like it's not like misunderstood where they're
like we don't know if he actually did we all knew we all
fucking knew what they did it's not like they're like but
Did he, no, he did do it.
We all knew he did do it.
There is an unbelievable amount of evidence that they did
what they did.
And even after everybody knew what they fucking did,
they still had multiple prison wives.
Oh yeah, even Dalmer.
Oh yeah, I remember that.
And his fangirls, who fought?
They don't, my God, was, That's so funny.
I can fix him.
People make mistakes.
People change.
I remember seeing, I don't remember who it was.
It might have been Ted Bundy, but I watched an interview of,
like, one of the fucking, like, serial killers.
And, like, he was, like, diagnosed as a sociopath.
Like, literally committing several murders.
And then, like, an interviewer was doing an interview on
him.
And he, like, people were like, oh, man, he just seems
misunderstood.
Because, you know, if you're a sociopath, you can make, you
can, like, pretend you have empathy and stuff.
And, uh, and then, like, they're like, oh, yeah, like, I,
like, I didn't really mean to do that, you know?
like reading the YouTube comments and people are like, man.
And then some guy, like others were like, bro, what the
fuck?
This guy is a little like, oh, it's psychopath.
Sorry.
Is it no, sociopaths also are similar.
Is it?
I forgot.
What's the difference between sociopaths?
Uh...
No.
Yeah, no.
Okay, Psycho.
I feel like Psycho.
They're not the same thing.
I'm trying to remember what the difference between a
sociopath and a psychopath.
Um.
Oh, sorry.
A psychopath.
Yeah.
No.
A psychopath is the one where you actually have no empathy.
Sociopaths are where you can have empathy.
But it's like not really, not that much.
It's psychopaths that are like actual no empathy at all.
Uh, Manny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That would not have survived that met that guy before they
were arrested.
I'm trying to like remember.
who it was i was like it was like really interesting too was
it ted bundy interview because it was a very interesting
interview i was like watching it was it this
let's see
i don't remember i wish i remember who it was because the
interview was so interesting
listen Allison Matt oh my god I can fix their Dublin thank
you for the super chat thank you guys I don't know guys guys
I don't know
guys it might not be Might not be the smartest thing to do.
All right, back to work, guys.
Back to work.
Enough about the murder talk.
It's back to work time.
Ba-dum.
Ba-dum-dum.
I don't
have more messages.
That's crazy.
oh my gosh like uh i i bought like okay so like you know how
like i have i'm autographing stuff for merch um so like i
bought like four different marker like autographed like
autographed marker brands because I've never had to like
actually like autograph because like you know all the other
autographs in the past I've done was digitally where I just
like do it digitally and then they just print it out so I've
never had to like actually hand sign anything with like an
actual autograph marker so like I was like um um like I just
remember this because I was like replying back to messages
and uh so I was like testing out the markers because I don't
know which is a good I was Like, I actually even read, like,
I even watched, like, videos where they're doing, like, they
were, like, doing, like, like, autographed marker reviews
and stuff.
I was just like, I was just like, I was like, oh my gosh.
Like, what is a good marker?
Yes, dude, yes.
So I had to, like, research because there's, like, I didn't
want to get, like, a normal Sharpie.
Like, because, like, you know, people, obviously, like, you
can just get it right.
the sharpie but there's actual autograph markers but i
needed one that was like a good brand and um and like i want
the colors to pop and stuff so like um i bought like i think
like four different fucking autograph brands i even had to
like i even had to like um ask my friend sachi too like i I
was like, I was like, I was like, which one do I get?
I was so fucking, bro, bro, I was so fucking, I bought so
many.
I bought so many brands.
Uh, Jordan, thank you for the Magenta Supa.
Thank you.
Congratulations on your success.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you for the Magenta Supa.
and she suggested i tried the uh what was it called the
secure pen touch i'm waiting for that right now i'm waiting
for that to arrive
i wish there's a pin i wish there was a pin feature on
discord because there's like some that i'm like oh um i want
to reply back to it but at a later time
there are?
No, like, but like pin like people.
That's what I mean.
I'm not meant like messages but like I meant like I want to
pin like not messages, like pin the person.
That's what I want.
Yeah, I want to keep them because like Twitter recently
added that too, which is very helpful.
Twitter added like a feature where you can pin like Twitter
DMs.
but like you can't do that on uh you can't do that on this
one on discord
okay oh my god i did it i finished answering individual
discord dms all right how many percentage did i finish with
that done answered dms
And there you have it, 20%.
The moment I do one more task, I win.
We're still winning?
Well, for now, the second task I can get done, like, in the
next 20 minutes, so you're fucked, guys.
Quick, someone DMed Toki.
Why are you adding more?
Someone add Dewey Flip.
What the fuck is get good?
Dark Blade, they give us the chat.
Thank you.
you mercy thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
now that the unread dms are answered how many dms have been
left unread this month i'll never tell you thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you
let's see hey
I'm sorry There's Oh my god I wish I can show you guys this
You guys Oh well You guys are gonna see it later Later You
guys will see it one day But I got shown something really
fucking funny For my next secret project One day By the time
I show this And you'll know why I thought it was so funny oh
my god okay it's just so funny i have to show i need you
guys to see this like i just love this guy i just love
looking at this all right there's like no you have zero
context as to what this is for but it's just so funny i have
to show it
I love it.
There's zero context.
I just, I just love those guys' expressions.
You have zero context.
You just get to see this.
Why is he like that?
There's no context for you.
Okay
But I'll just put him here
He's just gonna be standing here
Fuck, okay.
Oh my god, I wish I could show you guys this now Sorry.
I wish I could show you guys.
Those are so fucking dumb.
Don't worry.
Soon, TM.
Soon.
I just saw something so funny.
Soon, TM.
Soon.
How the fuck did some of these things go on to your to-do
list?
One just says America, yeah.
Like, what?
The other one's like, what the fuck does potato mean?
What is the potato for?
Like,
Hello, hello.
Well, you got it.
Someone check that off.
Technically, it's done now.
That's another task done.
Have you not walked your dog yet?
Where did you put that on the to-do list?
Your dogs need a pee!
Bro!
Did you just add it?
When did you add this?
Oh, you just added.
Okay.
It's okay.
Sorry, I'll stop judging.
You literally just added it.
Thank God.
I was gonna be like, Oh my God, bro, your dog.
You can walk your dog!
Yeah, I could make the list, like, longer.
to show up.
No, I think it's...
Actually, no, it's the perfect height.
At least somebody.
Those people are Ashley.
Where the fuck?
Okay.
Flying potato wrote fucking become immortal.
These are the people that are sabotaging you.
Like...
These are the drag rooms that are fucking over the others.
Okay.
Alright.
I think I'm done on this.
Okay.
channel
all right I finished another task
all right nice I'm ahead now all right guys I gave you a
head start too like what the fuck guys we're never finishing
our task Mike thank you for the gift and ship thank you
thank you double mics Mike VC and Mike Tyson Thank you for
the gifted membership.
Thank you.
You saw that we are being sabotaged.
It's your...
Okay, you have no one to blame by yourself.
Not gonna lie.
Like, what the fuck did I do?
Like...
I'm just doing my task.
Bro, wrote that.
Finish 1P.
Do literally nothing.
I think like the mods gave up.
Sorry, the singular mod.
Gave up on trying to fucking moderate the...
I mean, to be fair, I would give up too.
To be fair Anyone would There's like freaking so many tasks
I already I started doing my own work They're free now
They're still here They're just not moderating the to-do
list anymore Like I'm surprised they lasted this long
honestly honestly I'm just surprised they were able to last
this long trying to moderate this mess of a to-do list this
to-do list is so fucked
we behaving what you mean literally i'm i can't literally
i'm looking back as like get eaten out by from black letter
and get eaten out by mike tyson yeah you guys are definitely
behaving
yeah from mr black letter himself
scrolling up like five minutes ago.
Someone had manual breathing.
Wait, hold it on.
Don't judge Sarah Bishop.
There he is.
There!
There he is!
Now he's on the stream!
another task completed guys
I think I won I don't think you're gonna catch up now
it's over many thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you Mike Tyson himself infiltrated the stream thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you Chad, stop adding more.
I don't know, guys.
I think Ducky's gonna beat us.
We don't know yet.
I may be wrong.
All right, guys.
We're gonna call it here.
All right, race is over.
Because, like, you know, I don't think it was much of a
competition in the end.
But, yeah.
I had a great time.
Just, like, no, I'm fucking...
Of course not rest of the tubers are over.
I'm fucking, I mean, like, setting up stuff for it.
But anyway, I'm going to call it here so I can grab
something to eat.
But I had a great time just hanging out with you guys,
getting some work done.
It was pretty comfy.
It was a comfy time to chill.
I really like this widget, though.
I think it's very, honestly, I feel like it, I hope it was
productive from you guys, for you guys as well.
their time just like hanging out and relaxing everybody um
and uh and i hope the widget has been quite helpful in
general um i really like seeing like you guys like you know
working alongside with me with the task and everything don't
worry guys i'll throw you guys a bone here what is the
command again let's see oh here you go guys watch this
Wait, actually, I'm worried I'm gonna do the wrong I'm gonna
put the wrong command Okay, give me a sec, guys Give me a
sec before I fucking accidentally Lock everything
Alright, guys, watch this
Oh Don't run!
That was the wrong
No!
Wait!
Oh, okay.
I figured it out.
Did I do
it?
What?
Yay!
Oh, shit!
Nice.
Now none of us.
Nobody wins.
Now nobody wins.
No, I'll just do this and finish to do this Done, finish to
do this Now nobody, now I win
This is so funny
Look at that, you're still fucking, you're still adding more
stuff to to-do list.
What do you mean, Rage?
Yay, 100%.
Stop the count.
You guys are still fucking adding more stuff.
What do you mean?
Stop moving the cold post.
We got things to do.
You're still adding more stuff.
What do you mean?
Medi-ing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Here's how dragoons can still win.
Stop adding stuff.
Exclamation point.
Add.
I can't believe I'm the only one that finished the to-do
list, guys.
We can't end the stream till this start.
Well, unfortunate, everybody.
Hey guys, I had a great time.
I had a great time.
Just, uh, you can't even complete the task until 10 minutes
later.
There's still a slow bone.
It was all rigged against you.
No matter what, Tokyo, the house always wins.
Uh, Kaz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Nah, nah, we won round one.
Oh, but it was nice just relaxing.
Um, sorry.
not a super long stream.
I think it's because, like, I did, like, a really long
stream for Stajab Slam.
So, like, honestly, this today is just more so of chill.
And tomorrow, there's, like, double streams, too.
So this is more so of, like, an appetizer.
Just a chill session with everybody.
A hangout session, like, some solo hangout session with you
guys.
Black, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What did you do?
I haven't finished one piece yet.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
um but yes everybody i'm gonna go head out now gonna eat
dinner and then get more work done but as always everybody
stay hydrated pause to check get them around to get that
blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed because
you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye
guys